Challenges yes. Challenges from them and there was a time. I think it was perhaps five six maybe even seven years ago.
It appeared that the. The whole spec scene was getting at of control in the streets of newman again. And then that.
It seemed to go through a period of easing off i don't know if economic conditions in the outside world have been who
with the. Fluctuating number of junkies that seem to come to town.
It appears from what i've heard to be going to another. Upswing. Rotten there.
I mean it's obviously a shame for the people who work in them and the shanta people who go on the smack to you know.
This i for one. But i don't think that it's anything that will drag the town under. And so the town the killing.
Because the town is just like a visual. Manifestation of a lot larger.
Core of people you know and there are thousands of people you never see illustrated down to that or atma hills
or perhaps they're chopping them in because i don't like the in-town feeling. But this story.
I don't i can't see any real challenges that newman can't. Succumb.
I think the tourist challenge is perhaps the biggest one we've faced year in a lot of ways
and a lot of people feel very strongly about it. You know very anti tourist. Don't come staring at us.
There then we're just living our life piss off. I don't want a few tourists.
That's what we have we go overseas and challenges our council you know thing that. That's going to bring us down.
It will just go from strength to strength. Take over the world. Niman today. Tomorrow. The universe. To pleasure. Ok.
Mama. Fun celebration. Bob bob is. The one that really sticks in my mind. Was the house warming party. That we have.
When we've finished building our house daughter and myself. And we'd planned it a hassle of.
At least six months before it happened and.
Had a very optimistic attitude as to how long it would take us to build this house that we were building.
Having never will that hammer
and sold you for my life i didn't need tools were like i had a boy my first heaven saw when i wanted to build a house.
And we do it his house we've had.
I feel a little bit of a problem with the council in terms of forgetting to contact them first about it.
And he issued us with stuff work notices and the. Weeks before the party was due. But when it eventually i did.
The they had we'd moved into the house. Twenty four hours before the party and. You had no furniture.
Had nothing in the house at all and maybe one hundred fifty people turned up. Out in the middle of nowhere.
Like to me it seemed like it was right in the middle of the bush.
There was no at the houses you could see for this far as the arkansas. And there were all these people in my house and.
Everybody had brought a cushion. And it was just wonderful it went from bad to dies and. Stuck in my mind.
And stuck right there in this image of this wonderful party was his close friend of mine who'd just got out of hospital.
Two days before after being in traction for six months with a broken hip. From a car accident.
And he sat in the one arm chair that we had that somebody had brought an arm chair for him and he. Sat in his chair.
All. All not nice the next day with a big small in size. And it was just wonderful. Doner admired some rather.
Overly strong. Cookies and everybody had a really wonderful time on. So you know what. So. Oh yes.
A lot of a good party i think is the common thread and. The the bonding. That people get.
When you have a really big happy successful celebration. Together you know. It's the old some is greater than the.
Or that the whole is greater than some other parts of australia.
Is that when there's a group get together to celebrate and. It's a good.
Working celebration it seems to achieve something. That that feeling of unity.
I think that a lot of people need to continually reassess and reestablish that feeling of unity with the.
Kindred spirits.
I think that's perhaps one of the bonding forces in the area is that feeling of kindred in this between the people who
are here. Hi i'm jill. Jill giant.
And i came here in a she went away for a couple of years and then came back to live permanently and i d.
To think it was when my son was old enough to go to school.
He needed a bit of the bison before that i was a travelling hippie. And now i've found.
After living in the bush and having babies in their living houses.
Which i'd love to do and growing vegetables and all that it's.
Now i've needed something a bit more creative to find meaning in. Life with your life.
So are established a fabric painting. Business which. I really love to do.
And it's brought me closer to a lot of people and i've been i would share my skills with a lot of people
and then been get some of the kids a bit more inspired
and guided into doing something creative which makes them feel really good about and.
I got a great shed that i working from home.
Which is very lucky i'm one of the few houses here that's got mine's power.
So i couldn't do it otherwise it's on the lockers and that sort of thing. And.
And it attracts a lot of people here on to the community.
Of diverse people i've had a woman from the gold coast in fact yesterday i came down who's interested in mocking some
of the. And it's really interesting too. To have a focal point like that to attract all these are different people and.
That's a good mating point. And it's also good for the. You know the broader area to have a bit of an economy.
You know and. You know being out to generate money and also the tourists coming into the area they're always.
All wanting something unusual to take a while with them and there's very few things.
All this getting more and more products in the shops for people to buy and take away.
So that's a big part of it as well. As scrooge where we live. Yeah. Living in the bush i mean.
You just look at the wind. It's just inspiring. This.
And it's all so new in this so much diversity in patterns and colors. Within the people the environment.
The conversations that you have it's all.
Feeding you constantly off
and sort of move back to the city i don't think i could be as creative because it's sort of it's.
You know i think whereas here. The bush and.
There's always different ideas and different color schemes you know in a way into the blue collars
and sunny diets already in orange and yellow. Yeah.
So yeah i came here with a three year old for the city because we lived. When i lived in new zealand we didn't have.
We didn't believe in any money we live totally.
Sustainably we used to pick mussels off the rocks and sell them and sex once a month we had a bow.
And with the money we made from that we bought six of ross six of waste and six of sugar. And we used to fish.
In those walpole. And those cry fish. And we had an incredibly abundant life from the land all. That's all we. We used.
What was around us.
And
when i first came to nimbin from new zealand i couldn't believe coming to nimbin gee nobody had fish to balls in the ground
like i thought they were just playing it being able to manage it you know how.
And it took me a while to get used to that but i mean you're straddling government and it's magnanimity.
What it is the word is just paid us to live here in paradise shall i thought well well that's ok thank you very much.
And now i can get into other things apart from growing vegetables and.
You know doing the basics and i think we've been very very lucky.
For years and i don't know how long it's going to continue.
But i think it's something that we've all got to look at that it's not going to keep going for ever
and we do have to create another economic sort of bice at this number and this area can sustain itself
and that's one of the challenges i guess that i can see from them been creating a different economy based not on what
mine strains by storm but more. Bball in the sense of like you know the whole permit culture thing.
On the whole getting vegetable. Thing.
And with the says a lot of tourists and a lot of visitors coming to the town that.
You know that really wants things and they gonna lie still with money in their pockets and empty and.
You know there's a very there's a really big market in there that has to be that would be good to tap into.
And a positive i think is possible. Now because of avalos very high.
That's what i found in new zealand for three years survival was number one and you didn't have time.
I mean we had a beautiful. We had.
You know a lot stalls fantastic what we ate what we talked about the music we had and all that but.
It was very much of a struggle.
You know twenty four hours a diver chile you were working all the time whereas i think the dolls given us the freedom
to. Well build comfortable houses and giving us the time to go off and.
You know create more interesting things to do rather than just the toil of a happy doll bludgers.
The last say if you delve less i see it as a rural subsidy. And i see a lot of people.
Doing really worthwhile
and important things with the money that we gained while building a house for example rather than being tapped into the
mortgage belt for forty years or whatever. Have a long people get tapped into.
And yeah it's like a subsidy to say ok you know a lot you can populate this area but after a while i think. Inherently.
You know when you've got everything pretty well set up then it's time that we got the freight
and we haven't got the financial pressure. You know that we can create these new.
Little industries dr around the countryside
and that so i've seen them been developing with a whole lot of small business. And really creative dynamics.
And i think that's because we live in such a wrong. Environment we've.
We're not because if we lived in europe where there's been people living for thousands of years you'd sort of somehow
it infiltrates into your very bones the big. You know your very being.
And that's what everybody thinks and talks about whereas here it's all very new
and it's this whole new i just incredibly strong in people's conversations and how they dress.
How they express themselves.
And all that sort of thing is a sense of well being he said to you sometimes
when i get out they are to go down to the city i think. Come on i think. You know the world changing everyone's.
You know it's getting better. And i go out there i think oh i think i live in a little cocoon up here.
I think there is a sense of. We are but separate and different from everybody but i think this gold coast woman that.
Kind the other day she's really wiking out and talking about some new age stuff and. I think it's happening a lot of.
I think nimbin is a real nucleus of it.
And i think the rest of the world slowly followings like health foods you know ten years ago nobody had amused earlier
as everybody eats and now. We've been eating it for twenty years and brown ross and tofu and all that.
And i think we are a bit of a bit of a leader and him so a lot staal and food
and all that sort of thing environmental issues of course that's always been. Top of the priority list.
Terms of people creating more sustainable was to live. Simple directions.
As long as you know they just yeah everybody's. Living enough.
Well i don't see it as a negative thing i said i would say. I don't say.
I see all the relationships at a gun through really hard times at the moment in the last. Few years.
I see it as it will grow a challenge i see it as a real growth.
Thing for growing you have to really look at yourself you gotta look at sun many different issues rather than just
hanging in there with. Putting up with things that are good for you and good for kids.
I think we all tain specially with the women around here we all get together and talk a lot about personal stuff
and relationships and that sort of thing and i think it's we all grow and we're all a lot more compassionate and was
and. More capable of having. Better quality relationships and. You know the average person.
She's always been with pressures from living. While living.
You know quite difficult to build your own house in most places. Was a factor.
Yeah i think for people living together twenty four. As if when people broke up around here it's.
You know we were living in each other's pockets twenty four hours a day seven days away you cannot think you do tend to
get a bit sick of each other.
Plus the whole struggle of surviving you know building houses
and having babies at the same time living in taints in the weight season and.
When you used the old color to even flush toilets.
Which we have most of this kind from it's really really hard
and then you often find with your partner quite happy to sort of live in a tent for four years.
Was it for us women especially with by a base you just want to keep doing that so yeah i think it created a lot of
tension and relationships. And just the hard yakka the hard work.
And then there's the whole feminist the whole sort of six sixes. Role.
Battle that went on like all the men out there with a child sewing and fixing the cars
and the women looking after the buy. And people feeling a bit sort of stuck in their roles. You know. That sort.
Thing i think created a lot of tension.
So all of this this world was about seeing neilsen females as being different and here late.
Not better not worse so i think some women love.
Might last six cars and using chime souls are the main like looking after by using cooking in the kitchen.
So if you lost. When you're using this as a single use have been for the last three or four years.
Look it's fantastic living in a community is all lies somebody look up to you kid so.
You know you can always share the whole parenting role. And for all the kids.
You know especially when i get older all i have had a few coming in and i need to talk about their problems
and i can't talk about it with their parents.
You know for the kids there's a lot more adult interaction that i can get
and i can get in they'd met a lot more from other adults.
Rather than just their own parents because that was the one i think yes yeah well there are a lot more what must i
think yes. This is it yeah. Well most of the kids seem to be really comfortable with other adults.
And i like and walk into a room with adults and feel quite comfortable and sit there like come to a loud parties.
And they're not so shuffled away. And they're very much part of the whole.
Last fall he they are integrated and i think that's really really healthy i mean
when i was a kid you know any visits guymon you a shovel at the back door. Say in a not hood sort of thing.
And i think it gives the kids here a lot more law schools in terms of communicating and what i want. And i can.
They're a lot more compassionate about people with problems i mean we've had quite a few people in benji who have had a
few problems with mental problems and the kids just observe it in the. And.
There are a lot more equipped to deal with people when they're older than you know sort of just had their own adult.
Parents to rely to and. Want to get. Things. Downside. The kids here. I think the maybe. They often watch.
Are you know. Happy families on the telly like the cross be shot on a ladder and they allow the video.
And they are all there is and then come back and i got. Brown ross we can do a lot. And i often think that.
You know a few years ago we were all worried at all that kids were going to go off and want to be yuppie policemen
and lawyers and things like that.
You know with the maid the external world stepping in i think in a lot of kids' minds it creates. They're not so happy.
Rather have what i see on the telly. But as i get older i think that i realise what that.
What that guy and he were and. You know it's not such a big get that they say.
Is because you know come on those things. Cues. One way to get.
Yeah yeah yeah well at the moment this is one of my things there's not a lot for the kids to get into.
There's no not much work. You know it's a real pity.
Nimbin ha school put in a submission to go on to eleven twelve and it was not
but for the last make i cannot understand why there's so many kids.
Coming up to that i got to jump in this bus and go on to lismore and back
and then been school was going to offer a lot of diversity in terms of the schooling hours i could pick and choose
when i came and went a lot of interesting. You know like the woodwork and middle work in the.
All that sort of thing was going to be very strong personal development subjects were going to be strong as well as i
say and. That was a real.
Blood tomato a lot of kids a lot of kids going to school to use before they really shouldn't cause you know fifteen
sixteen you know. Very immature. To call it was a lot. When you say seventeen after you've been through the system.
So that's a real pity but i'll just say for a lot of the kids that the that it's slowly happening
but we need to provide more work experience. You know. For them to tap into when they get older this.
You know rather than having to go to the city or just to sit around on the ball when they finish school.
That's very important to you now. And the sun i'm out at all the statistics out of the sun many kids now.
Coming of age from.
You know the seventy's that's what i ten years ago we got all these i ten year old kids that were born from the.
Aquarius time and i really need something to decay into. So that's a that's a real challenge for them and then that.
Maze a real hard priority.